لذلك وقع الزلزال في المغرب بقوة
6.8 درجة في 11-11 بالتوقيت المحلي
ليلة الجمعة وكان العمق حوالي 11 ميلًا
وهو ما قد يبدو عميقًا جدًا ولكن
في الواقع عندما تتحدث عن
المعايير الجيولوجية فهو في الواقع
زلزال ضحل جدًا مما يعني أنك
سوف  أشعر بها أكثر من ذلك 7. 4.9
هزة ارتدادية بعد 19 دقيقة تم الشعور بها
في الجزائر وكذلك البرتغال، لذلك شعرت بأنها
بعيدة جدًا، وهو أمر نادر جدًا منذ عام
1900، ولم تحدث سوى تسعة زلازل
بقوة خمس درجات أو أعلى،
لذلك شعر الكثير من الناس بشدة
هزات قوية شعر ما يقرب من 3 ملايين شخص
بهزات قوية وشعر ما يقرب من نصف
مليون شخص إما بالاهتزازات القوية جدًا أو الشديدة
مع هذا
الزلزال بالذات، لذا فإن الهزات الارتدادية التي تبلغ قوتها 5.8 هناك
عادةً ما يمكن أن يشهد متوسطها ما يصل
إلى 100 زلزال بقوة 3.8
أو أكبر.  في الأيام
وحتى الأسابيع القادمة بعد الزلزال الأولي، يعد هذا أمرًا
مهمًا خاصة وأن
الكثير من المباني والهياكل قد
تعرضت بالفعل للخطر من
الزلزال الأولي وبالتالي فإن أي زلازل إضافية يمكن أن
تسبب المزيد من الضرر، وهذا هو
الخوف الكبير، والشيء الآخر الذي يجب مراعاته هو
يمضي الطقس قدمًا مع
جهود التعافي، سيكون الجو حارًا للغاية
خلال اليومين المقبلين
وسيظل جافًا ولكن درجات الحرارة المرتفعة
ستكون في التسعينات المنخفضة مع أدنى مستوياتها في
منتصف الستينيات